let's see where do we want to go next oh
I don't know let's go let's go to mark
from Newport whoo we haven't heard from
for several months mark from Newport
what's going on
today hey David thanks for taking my
call in your progressive sense
self-censorship video when you were
discussing Israel you had mentioned that
you oppose the right wing Netanyahu
government where I completely agree you
had mentioned that you support Israeli
withdrawal from the West Bank where I
completely agree but you also mentioned
that you supported complete Israel
Israeli withdrawal from East Jerusalem
and I was just wondering if you could
explain that a bit more
oh so it's a little more nuanced than
that but I didn't you know the segment
wasn't fully about that so the the
scenario I envision as from a pragmatic
perspective leading to real prospects
for an agreement to be done and this is
of course like assuming we can even get
to negotiations which were nowhere near
being able to get to I I envisioned that
to get agreement for a two-state
solution East Jerusalem would become a
part of the Palestinian territories but
within that Israel would retain control
of the Jewish quarter of the old city i
I see that as pretty non-negotiable so
it's a little more nuanced than I said
in that segment that's probably how I
would imagine it working out okay that
that makes a bit more sense what about
specific specifically control inside the
temple now I know we both we've both
been there and I've heard you tell your
story about visiting about going inside
on the show what do you think should
what do you think should be the case
with the status of control inside the
Temple Mount which right now is under
the under control of the law yeah I
think that it is going to be very
difficult to again I'm thinking
pragmatically I don't know how you don't
leave control over the Temple Mount to
you know whether it's Jordanian
authorities or what become Palestinian
authorities it just seems like that is
going to be a sticking point in any
serious negotiation I just
I don't know how Israel even justifies
taking control back of it sure and then
my last question super quick was a lot
of progressives as I'm sure you've heard
are increasingly supporting a one state
just a one state democracy as a solution
for the conflict which to me sounds far
you to you tote at utopia n-- is
something I could even take seriously
just being familiar with it I need the
dynamics underground there yeah I was
curious your view on just on a
bi-national democracy yep I support a
two-state solution is it full stop could
you and would you entertain it at all I
mean listen I I won't video if someone
wants to bring to me a one state
solution that would not be subject to
all of the problems of all of the other
one state solution ideas that we've seen
so far I will entertain it but as of
right now I support a two-state solution
period okay I that that's where I'm at
as well I support a two-state solution
period and but I keep hearing the I just
keep hearing one state solution
rhetoric more and more and more on the
left understandably but it just seems
too too far-fetched to me but hey thank
you very much for taking our call David
all right Marc from Newport great to
hear from you